meanwhile another vaccine maker moderna
says it's beginning tests on a new
booster shot
targeting one of the covet variants that
is spreading rapidly
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in los angeles
this morning david good morning to you
some good news good morning the concerns
over that covet variant first detected
in south africa continue to grow the
variant is now in at least 14 states
and data suggests it could reduce the
protection that people are getting from
existing vaccines
so the drug companies are now worsening
working on those booster shots that
means folks who
already have gotten vaccinated might
have to get back in line
it has been about a week now since
antonio whiteley got his second dose
of the moderna vaccine he is an
acupuncturist who practices holistic
medicine
and says he jumped at the chance to get
vaccinated because he's a designated
health care provider
i'm not afraid of it and i trust science
but now he may have to get an additional
booster shot from modern
am i thrilled uh no
because maybe even after this booster
what if there's another booster after
that
that is a real possibility according to
modernist president dr stephen hogue
well i think we all hope that this
doesn't become something that happens
for everybody every year in the same way
as it currently does but it is
definitely
true that we could run into a situation
where we're ultimately needing to
provide a booster vaccine
every year or every few years based on
the evolution of the virus
now moderna is not alone there are other
vaccine manufacturers all racing to
develop boosters
they'll all need to go through the fda's
approval process but that could go
quicker than you think
thanks partly to the success of earlier
large-scale vaccine trials
agency officials say smaller shorter
studies could assure the safety of the
variant booster shots now those trials
would require hundreds not thousands of
participants
and it could take only a few months this
is actually not a change in the
effectiveness of the vaccine it's the
evolution of the virus
and so the vaccines are highly effective
that's been proven in clinical trials
but the virus isn't going to give up
just with one fight and that's why mr
whiteley says he'll line up for the next
one if he needs one
i will do what it takes to stop the
spread of this so
if there is a booster i will have no
problems saying yes
to taking that booster so we asked dr
hogue
with moderna about the concerns
vaccinated people have about the
possibility of needing multiple booster
shots as the virus continues to mutate
he says
it is possible we could end up needing a
booster annually or
maybe even more often than that but he
notes that many people put up with
getting the flu shot every year
he says with covet it would be a small
inconvenience to get our lives back on
track
i'll say david i'm from to do whatever
it takes to get our lives back school
thank you very much